after a couple years of wearing
sweatpants and loungewear it's your time
to put your best look for lifestyle
expert davey sutton is back to the show
to show us how to refresh your wardrobe
this season check it out
hey friends if you're looking to level
up your wardrobe but don't know where to
start feeling a bit overwhelmed then
stitch fix may be your perfect shopping
solution just fill out the survey online
to give the stylist a sense of your
personal style then the pressure is off
you and the experts get to work picking
out pieces you can add to your wardrobe
check out a few of my favorite looks
from my fix and you can tailor your fix
to what you're looking for from
graduation to brunch with the girls to
vacation ready outfits your fix is
filled with five curated pieces from
more than one thousand of your favorite
brands in style to try on in the comfort
of your home shipping and returns are
always free and there's no subscription
required to get started with your
personalized shopping experience visit
stitchfix.com
okay so next we want to work on putting
our best face forward and we know that
facial oils have been having their
moment so let me introduce you to mckee
berry oil by vimigus so this is a pure
100 cold pressed oil from chile it has
zero fillers it's known as the world's
most powerful super fruit the maki berry
contains the highest level of
antioxidants which neutralize free
radicals and can reduce cell damage so
what that means for us is that it helps
slow down the signs of aging and it
helps to promote healthy glowy skin and
we only just need a few drops so this
little bottle will last us a long time
to purchase visit
thirteenloon.com finally we're looking
good we're dressing good now let's add a
little gina sequoia with your own
signature fragrance the french brand
diptique is passionate about their range
of fragrances and candles in fact they
say creating fragrances is an art and
art is a journey and you certainly can
take people who have the pleasure of
smelling you on a wonderful journey so
the process of finding your signature
fragrance can be daunting i love that
diptique has these discovery sets that
you can build on your own you can go in
store or select from the online
selection you pick out five fragrances
and it comes in a cute little box like
this e voila you're on your way to being
that person who has a little bit of
essence about them for more information
visit diptek.com